Путін готував підґрунтя для вторгнення в Україну вже давно.
Зокрема у промові незадовго до початку війни він озвучив:
Маю на увазі розширення блоку НАТО на схід.
Він закинув Північноатлантичному альянсу розширення - дедалі ближче до російських кордонів.
Та звинуватив західних лідерів у порушенні начебто даних раніше обіцянок не робити цього.
Серед інших це й обіцянка нашій країні не розширяти ні на дюйм НАТО на схід.
Однак експерти стверджують, що це - неправда.
США уже спростували ці твердження.
Гадаю, це неправда. Це справді лише щось на кшталт приводу.
То чи дійсно Кремлю щось обіцяли?
І чому це настільки важливо для Росії?
Після Другої світової війни у Європі виникли дві зони впливу, кожна - із власним військовим альянсом.
На заході - НАТО, на сході - країни, що згодом приєдналися до Варшавського договору.
Це створило умовну червону лінію між сферами впливу СРСР і США.
Ці сфери було чітко визначено, аж поки 1990-го року цей порядок почав розвалюватися - тут, у Німеччині.
Німеччина була фактично центром "холодної війни" у Європі…
Джошуа Шіфрінсон провів ґрунтовне архівне дослідження міжнародної політики США та Радянського Союзу.
…зокрема й ключового питання - що ж було обіцяно в 1990-му.
У ті часи Німеччина прагнула об'єднання. І багатьох у Європі це дещо лякало.
США не хотіли бачити об'єднану Німеччину ані в радянському таборі, ані нейтральною.
Побоювалися, що в разі нейтралітету Німеччина одного дня знову зірветься.
У Вашингтоні вирішили, що найкращим рішенням було б узяти Німеччину до НАТО.
Але спершу слід було переконати у цьому Радянський Союз.
І ось тут ми підходимо до питання так званих гарантій щодо нерозширення НАТО, на які так активно посилається Путін.
У лютому 1990 року під час низки зустрічей лідери США і Західної Німеччини відкрито заявили:
якщо радянські лідери занепокоєні об'єднанням Німеччини й тим, що країна залишиться членом НАТО,
то Альянс не розширюватиметься ані на дюйм на схід.
Відтоді записи цих розмов було розсекречено. І світ побачив, що саме західні лідери сказали радянським політикам...
Як-от канцлер Німеччини Гельмут Коль (10 лютого 1990).
Генсек НАТО Манфред Вьорнер (1 липня 1991).
І знамениті слова держсекреатаря США Джеймса Бейкера.
Тож, що сталося з НАТО після об'єднання Німеччини?
У 1999 році Чеська республіка, Угорщина та Польща приєдналися до НАТО.
У 2004 - країни Балтії та ще чотири інші держави.
І нарешті ще чотири країни - з 2009-го й донедавна.
Грузії та Україні теж пообіцяли членство в НАТО, але цього не сталося.
Чи виправдовує це претензії Путіна?
Одну й ту саму історичну подію можна трактувати по-різному.
1991 року Радянський Союз розпався.
Це Стівен Пайфер. Він був послом США в Україні, коли НАТО розширювалося,
і заступником директора так званого радянського відділу, коли робилися обіцянки.
Коли держсекретар Бейкер тоді говорив про подальше нерозширення НАТО,
я зрозумів, що йдеться лише про Східну Німеччину.
За словами Пайфера, ці обіцянки не поширювалися на такі країни, як Польща або Литва, тому що...
У ті часи ще існував Варшавський договір.
І він проіснував ще рік. Тож я сприймав ці розмови щодо жодного дюйму - дійсно лише у контексті Німеччини.
Це не витримує критики з двох причин.
По-перше, й радянські, й американські лідери розуміли, що питання того, що далі, стосується цілої Східної Європи, а не лише Німеччини.
Були побоювання, що Варшавський договір розвалюється.
Крім того, якщо я обіцяю, що не піду на схід - це загальне твердження, так?
Це трохи маніпуляція - думати, що вони мали на увазі: схід - це лише тут, а не там.
Пайфер, утім, має на це інший аргумент у відповідь.
Коли ви подивитеся на реальні договори, там немає остаточних зобов'язань щодо нерозширення НАТО.
Іншими словами: жодних угод, лише розмови.
Це не внесли до документів, але з іншого боку - дипломатичні  угоди завжди дещо розмиті...
Саме так завершилася Карибська криза.
І якби ці усні домовленості не мали значення, навіщо тоді дипломатам узагалі розмовляти?
Якими б не були усні запевнення, їм не вистачає підкріплення.
Розширення НАТО краще унаочнити, якщо зосередитися не на розмовах, а на залучених до процесу гравців.
З одного боку - США, чий вплив значно зріс після розпаду СРСР.
Розширення НАТО - побічний продукт однополярної ери. Це відбувалося у часи, коли США мали величезну силу й мало обмежень.
І деякі державні діячі вважали, що американська сила і вплив у світі можуть принести США багато товарів, а решті світу - добрих речей.
З іншого боку - це країни, які самі прагнули приєднатися до НАТО.
Це не НАТО казало: давайте розширятися.
Були країни на кшталт Польщі, що з'явилися зі спадку Варшавского договору і заявляли:
ми хочемо бути членами НАТО, ми хочемо бути членами Європейського Союзу,
і ми готові робити все, для цього необхідно.
І нарешті - Росія, чиї мотиви не обмежуються НАТО.
На мою думку, є три мотиви, що приховуються за діями Росії.
Перший - зовнішньополітичні ризики.
Росія хоче бути впливовою на пострадянському просторі, й Україна - важлива частина цього.
Другий - внутрішньополітичні ризики.
Для Кремля орієнтована на Захід демократична, економічно успішна Україна - це нічний кошмар Кремля,
адже це може підштовхнути росіян до думки:
а чому ми не можемо мати такого ж політичного голосу й таких же демократичних прав, які має Україна?
Й нарешті третій ризик, гадаю, це сам Володимир Путін, адже він дуже емоційно говорить про Україну.
Емоційно, навіть зі злістю.
Чи мусить НАТО дотримуватися усних обіцянок про нерозширення - спірне питання.
Ми недооцінили, наскільки негативно у Москві сприймалося існування НАТО.
Роки недооцінки обіцянок, що їх дали раніше й змусили Росію думати,
що Заходу не можна довіряти, дійсно звузили можливість для вирішення цієї кризи.
Але зараз це дійсно лише привід.
Путін накопичив всі образи на Захід, але він не висловлював їх протягом останніх 20 років.
Однак ці дискусії були важливими не лише з огляду на те, що вони обіцяли, але й що вони продемонстрували:
бажання до компромісів й готовність не переходити "червоні лінії" одне одного.
Роками ситуація довкола Росії змінювалася, і дедалі більше країн виявляли бажання приєднатися до НАТО.
Однак ситуація змінилася і всередині самої Росії: влада Путіна посилювалася,
і він ставав дедалі більш авторитарним та ізольованим.